the scp foundation has encountered and
contained some of the most fearsome
entities in human history and even some
from long before us shaved apes were
ever walking across the earth they've
gotten their hands on ancient gods
humanoid creatures with deadly powers
and more than one item with the capacity
to bring about the end of the world as
we know it but not everything at the scp
foundation can kill you or would even
want to sometimes an scp has no agenda
other than going about their lives
making friends or even helping people
instead of wanting to eat you for dinner
these entities would rather sit down for
a meal and a chat with you no
apocalyptic ambitions here just good
vibes today we're taking a look at some
of the friendliest scps of all time
first off is an scp that's just as sweet
as it is sad if you ever encounter
scp-4999
you probably don't have long left to
live that's not because it's going to
kill you or even hurt you but because
49.99 visits people who are already at
death's door manifesting as a humanoid
figure dressed in dark clothing
scp-4999 appears to a person about 20
minutes before their death as long as
the subject is awake and alone it will
then sit down near their bed and offer
them a cigarette it will then light one
for itself and as it smokes hold the
dying person's hand or place a
comforting hand on their shoulder it
will stay there with them providing a
silent sense of peace until they have
slipped away may not be friendly in the
most traditional sense but
scp-4999 a great deal of kindness and
compassion in making sure that no one
ever dies alone though some of the
friendliest scps are serious others are
quite silly this is the case for
scp-2991
the entity is a striped multicolored
scarf capable of changing lengths the
scarf appears to be sentient and behaves
in a docile manner communicating by
forming itself into the shape of letters
and spelling out words the scarf enjoys
attention and becomes bored if left in
its containment box for too long and as
expressed a desire to play when asked if
it was made to be fun the scarf
responded yes and then wrapped itself
around the interviewer's hand and then
went to sleep it does not seem to have
any interests other than playing and
spending time wrapped around people
keeping them warm and cozy it's
basically just an ordinary scarf except
it's able to move on its own and desires
the company of humans sounds pretty darn
friendly to us some scps are perfectly
nice friendly people who have no control
over their own anomalous properties and
would probably prefer just to live out a
mundane existence free from any unusual
activity unfortunately you don't always
get what you want and neither does
scp-507 507 is for all intents and
purposes an ordinary human man with one
notable exception against his will he
routinely finds himself teleported into
alternate dimensions appearing in them
and returning to his original one
seemingly at random aside from these odd
stressful occurrences 507 is a jovial
individual who enjoys meeting other scps
and chatting with researchers at the
foundation about the paranormal aside
from his dimension hopping he is no
different from any pleasant stranger you
might encounter on the street while some
entities like 507 behave like a neighbor
to the scp foundation others like
scp-131 are more like house pets
scp-131 refers to a pair of creatures
nicknamed the ipods two teardrop shaped
creatures about one foot high one orange
and one yellow with a single blue eye in
the middle of each of their bodies their
intelligence has been compared to common
house cats and they are very curious
loving to roll around the facility and
see what everyone is getting up to they
appreciate attention and affection and
seek more of it from those who they bond
to following them around like a lost
puppy they may look strange at first but
their behavior is downright adorable and
as you may know from some of our other
videos when certain deadly anomalies
like
scp-173 escape they can storm in and
save lives so they're not only adorable
they're adorable heroes sometimes an scp
with the best of intentions can cause
harm to foundation personnel without
meaning to this was the case for
scp-2337
a male corn crate bird capable of
vocalizations loud enough to cause
permanent hearing damage though he
possesses this ability he has never used
it to cause deliberate harm while in
foundation custody instead he simply
wants to chat with the personnel
speaking in a language similar to
english the bird which responds to the
name dr spanko is very cooperative and
always excited to speak with research
staff especially delighted when called
by his name he may be a bit loud from
time to time but who isn't he's not
malicious just enthusiastic sometimes an
scp's good intentions are not
misinterpreted or inadvertently harmful
but simply as helpful as they were meant
to be enter
scp-662 a small silver handbell that
when shaken summons a short well-dressed
classic british butler named mr deeds mr
deeds will address the ringer of the
bell by their name and title and perform
tasks for them he is extremely polite
and even when given a task that he does
not wish to or is unable to complete he
declines with the utmost respect his
style of friendliness may be more formal
but he's good company just the same and
we've heard he mixes a mean or in this
instance a nice drink too many of the
nicest scps to be around are similar to
pets but very few were deliberately
intended to live in one's home as a
companion
scp-111 is an exception 111 refers to a
species of invertebrates resembling
snails also referred to as dragon snails
unlike ordinary snails these creatures
are warm-blooded highly intelligent and
capable of breathing fire though they
should be handled with care hatchlings
are capable of imprinting on their
owners much like other baby animals and
likely would make a lovely pet for a
fireproofed household unfortunately they
are all in foundation custody so there
is no way to find out for yourself some
of the previous scps in this video are
similar to ordinary pets but scp-529
actually is an ordinary pet with one
small anomalous change
scp-529 or josie is a small house cat
with grey tabby markings and only half
of a body don't get upset she is not
injured or in any pain for some reason
the rear end of her body from tail to
the bottom of her rib cage is simply not
there the place where the cat's body
ends appears as pure black to the naked
eye and absorbs light the area does not
appear to be invisible but it is simply
not there in spite of this josie
experiences no adverse effects moving
around as if the back half of her body
were still there
there are no containment procedures in
place for josie and she is allowed to
freely roam the facility purring rubbing
up against personnel's legs for
attention playing with balls of string
and little mouse toys and begging for
pieces of cheese as a treat creatures
like josie the half cat provide a morale
boost to those that encounter them but
entities like scp-5094 can provide
material benefits to the lives of those
they meet and help them to make a change
for the better scp-5094
or miss j is the main character of a
children's educational cd-rom game
called miss jay's wiz kid schoolhouse
miss jay who is unable to leave the
computer program has only one interest
educating others she can teach a given
student about essentially any subject
including particle physics and cubist
sculpture she conducts her lessons over
the course of several days up to 30
hours in length with breaks for meals
and trips to the bathroom sprinkled
throughout test subjects who studied
with miss j have described her as the
best teacher they have ever had and she
helped a d-class leave the foundation
and begin a career studying criminal
justice she even recognized a former
student now a junior researcher at the
foundation and expressed delight at
seeing how far he had come since her
first lesson with them many of the
friendlier scps have a great deal of
knowledge they are eager to share and
one of the most eager out there is scp
scp-1867
or lord theodore thomas blackwood lord
blackwood identifies himself as a
british explorer and naturalist as well
as a war veteran which is a bit
perplexing considering he is also a neon
sea slug measuring only 4.6 inches in
length in spite of this he enjoys
telling anyone who will listen the tales
of his past expeditions which he has
been able to provide ample proof of lord
blackwood is happy to provide
entertainment and engaging tales of
adventure to anyone who would like to
take a listen to the stories of a sea
slug if you're interested in the company
of lord blackwood because of a fondness
for stories then you'll also want to
hear about scp-1230 1230 is a simple
unlabeled green hardcover book with
nothing strange about it at first glance
when it is opened the phrase a hero is
born can be seen on the first page the
reader looks at and the rest of the
pages will appear to be blank the true
anomalous effects of the book do not
kick in until the reader goes to sleep
there they will find themselves in a
fantastical world as the protagonist of
their own adventure story the dream
world feels real as real as the waking
world and the story is tailored to the
interests of the reader in the dreams a
bearded man in a green cloak appears
known as the bookkeeper and acting as
the voice of
scp-1230 he is helpful and kind
providing guidance to the dreamers and
attempting to ensure that they have a
wonderful time in their dream just
before the dreamer wakes up the man bids
them a sorrowful farewell and asks that
they please visit again soon it seems
that the book and its keeper want
nothing more than to give readers an
incredible experience and the chance to
live out their wildest dreams as the
hero of their own story speaking of
objects that help people fulfill their
dreams
scp-2203 devotes itself to fulfilling
romantic dreams in the waking world 2203
is a standard love tester machine which
upon use dispenses a card with the name
and address of a person as well as a bit
of advice of how to approach them this
person is intended to be the soulmate of
the subject and when the subject
approaches their chosen person they find
that there is an immediate spark test
subjects who sought out their assigned
person have found either a spouse a
lover or a lifelong best friend it
refuses to suggest matches to
individuals with a history of domestic
violence indicating that its intention
is to only make matches that will be
happy healthy and safe many of these
friendly scps display a strong desire to
help others however they can few show
this desire more strongly than scp-2295
2295 is a patchwork stuffed teddy bear
made from synthetic fiber and cotton
when it is near a human who has
experienced major trauma to an organ the
bear becomes active it will produce
scissors white thread and sewing needles
or a crochet hook and create a stuffed
version of the ailing organ the damaged
organ will somehow be replaced with this
new creation it sounds as if this is the
start of a horrifying story but it isn't
the stuffed organ will function
perfectly defying all known laws of
medicine and science the bear wants to
help so badly that if there are no
useful materials nearby it will use
stuffing and fabric from its own body to
construct these organs when the bear is
unable to help a subject it will do
whatever it can to cheer them up and
make them happy and has even been known
to hold the subject and cry if there is
nothing else it can do above all the
bear simply wants to help heal the hurt
and the sick without a doubt though the
friendliest scp that the foundation has
ever encountered is
scp-999 also known as the tickle monster
999 is a large massive orange slime that
wants nothing more than to play
socialize and make people happy its
behavior has been compared to that of a
dog enjoying the company of humans and
other creatures just touching its slimy
surface is enough to boost a person's
mood and the creature expresses special
interest in people who are unhappy or
suffering from emotional pain it refuses
to eat meat and goes out of its way to
prevent any harm to those around it even
taking a bullet for a person to save
their life 999 is such a delight to be
around that it even managed to make the
omnicidal rage of
scp-682 subside if only for a moment
dogs might be considered man's best
friend but scp-999 is giving them some
fierce competition for the roll though
it would probably want to be best
friends with a dog too and hey if you
want your own scp-999 to cuddle make
sure to check out scpswag.com to pick up
a tickle monster plush it's the next
best thing to having your very own
scp-999 to cuddle whenever you need a
little pick-me-up now go check out
scp-5031 yet another murder monster and
scp-999 and the most wholesome scps for
more scps that'll warm your heart and
put a smile on your face